these are my disclosures so i think everyone here is aware that the presence of sinus involvement
and aggressive B-cell non-hydrogel lymphoma is associated with poor outcomes and even patients
who are able to proceed with CAR-T or autologous stem cell transplant and these are the best
treatments we have for patients with relapsed sinus involvement and these patients still have
poor outcomes and unfortunately most of them progress a relapse so there's definitely a high
unmet clinical need for these patients. We also know that the CD20-Bispecific have a
favorable safety profile and high efficacy in patients with systemic relapsed or refractory
aggressive B-cell non-hydrogel lymphoma including DLBCL, high-grade B-cell lymphoma and mantle cell
lymphoma. But we have limited data on their activity and safety in patients with sinus
involvement as these patients were excluded from the pivotal clinical trials. However,
we we have emerging data that show that these antibodies are actually active in sinus involvement.
So I've listed here a few small series. There's a series from Dave and colleagues from UPenn that had
seven patients treated with Glofit, three patients achieved CR and 2PR. Dr. Brooks here and his large
multi-center retrospective study had five responsive valuable patients with sinus involvement.
Unfortunately, none of them responded and there's a small case series of three patients with Burkitt lymphoma
treated with Glofit and Paula, one of whom had leptomeningeal disease and achieved CR.
There are two important studies that show that the Bispecific can actually cross the
blood-brain barrier and in these two studies that it was was Glofitamab. Gottfried from the
City of Hope had four patients and there's another series from Europe with eight patients and in both
of these series patients received a patient with sinus involvement received Glofitamab.
And Glofitamab was detected in the CSF at very small concentrations only 0.1 to 0.4% of plasma concentrations.
But patient-derived CSF samples were able to induce T-cell cytotoxicity against B-cells
and in both series response clinical responses were seen without neurotoxicity.
We presented data at ASH last year as a part of multi-center retrospective study of patients with sinus involvement.
as a part of multi-center retrospective study of patients with different types of aggressive
B-Cell Null Hodgkin lymphoma treated at six U.S. medical centers, part of the Cuban Consortium.
This work was led by Kiran Turan, who's a fellow at MD Anderson. We had two cohorts,
one cohort with active CNS involvement and had 18 patients. So these are patients who had active
CNS disease at the time of the bispecific treatment initiation. But we also had a cohort
of patients with history of CNS involvement, but not active CNS disease at the time of the
bispecific treatment initiation, because in many of the pivotal trials, patients with history of
CNS involvement, even if not active, at enrollment were excluded. These are the baseline characteristics
for the two cohorts. Most patients received Glofit, but a small number of patients received
Epcor or Mocin. Most patients had DL-BCL and high-grade B-Cell lymphoma, but we had two
patients with Burkitt, mantle cell lymphoma, and primate.
In the active CNS cohort, 12 out of the 18 patients received the bispecific in combination
with other active agents, including BTKI, chemo, radiation, polatuzumab, or lenalidomide.
I'm going to focus on the outcomes for the active CNS cohort. So the median duration of the
Bispecific therapy was only two and a half months. So it's a very short follow-up
duration. The overall response rate was 56%, including CR and 33%. The CNS overall response
rate was 65%, including CR in six patients or 35%. And the median time to response was
short, 1.8 months. In the six months, PFS rate was 43%, and the six-month CNS PFS rate
was 53%. And the six-month overall survival rate was 53%. So the median response rate was
77%.
We tried to look at outcomes in different subgroups, but the numbers are very small,
so this is all just hypothesis generating. If you look at the last column to the right,
the CNS CR rate, we saw CRs with Glofit and also EPCo in patients with parenchymal disease
or leptomeningeal disease when the bispecific was given as monotherapy or in combination.
We saw CRs in DLBCL and primate.
So this is all just hypothesis generating. If you look at the last column to the right,
the CNS CR rate, we saw CRs with Glofit and also EPCo in patients with parenchymal disease or leptomeningeal disease when the bispecific was given as monotherapy or in combination. We saw CRs in DLBCL and primate.
primary CNS lymphoma, but not in high-grade or mantle cell lymphoma, but again, very small
numbers. Importantly, the CR rates seem to be similar in patients with prior CAR-T or CAR-T
naive patients. And then these are the survival curves. We looked at the outcomes with monotherapy
versus combination, and we didn't see differences. Importantly, with a median follow-up of 12 months,
we had six patients who achieved CNS-CR, who also had systemic CR, and none of these six
patients relapsed or received subsequent treatment with CAR-T or ALO or anything else,
which suggests that these CRs could be lasting. And then in terms of toxicity, we looked at CRS
and ICANS. The CRS rate in the overall cohort was 43%, which is what you'd expect, but the ICANS
rate was a little bit higher than expected, 25% of seven patients.
And the ICANS rate was high in both the prior and the active CNS cohort, so 30%, or three out of 10
patients in patients with prior history of CNS involvement, and 22% in patients with active
CNS involvement, which included grades two, three, and four. We looked at these seven patients with
ICANS, four had DL-BCL, two had mantle cell lymphoma, one had high-grade BCL, six patients
received Glowfit, and one Epco. Five of them received Glowfit, and one received Glowfit.
So we looked at these seven patients with ICANS, four had DL-BCL, two had mantle cell lymphoma,
received it in combination, four didn't develop CRS, and none of the four patients with active
CNS lymphoma who developed ICANS achieved CR, but three did respond and achieved PR.
There was another important study presented at ASH last year. I don't have their slides,
so I just included data from the abstract. It was a multi-center retrospective study
from Europe of patients with CNS involvement by B-cell non-Hodgkin lymphoma treated by Specifex.
The median final lines of
treatment were three, and almost half of the patients received prior CAR-T. In this series,
most patients received Epco, 73%. The overall response rate and CR rates were very similar to
our study, 66% and 37%, but the CR rate seemed to be higher with the combination. The median PFS
was 8.5 months, and the ICANS rate also in the study was higher than in patients without,
historical controls of patients without CNS involvement at 22%. Thank you.
Thank you.